[Music]
I don't care if it hurts
wanna have control
[Music]
I want you to know this
when I'm not around
you're so very special
I need to do something substantial in
order to get the attention of the clubs
why because they're exclusive and fun
and they lead to a better life
[Music]
people want to go on the internet and
check out their friends so why not build
a website that offers that friends
pictures profiles I'm talking about
taking the entire social experience of
college and putting it online
this idea is potentially worth millions
of dollars millions you stole our
website they're saying we stole the
Facebook I know what it said so did we a
million dollars isn't cool you know
what's cool a billion dollars you're
going to get left behind it's moving
faster than any of us ever imagine
they're Left Behind sue him in federal
court I can't wait to stand over your
shoulder and what you write if you guys
were the inventors of Facebook you'd
have that to Facebook is there anything
that you need to tell me your actions
could have permanently destroyed
everything I've been working on did you
like being a joke do you want to go back
to that Mark
this is our time
you're being accused of intentionally
breaching security violating copyrights
violating individual privacy
your best friend is suing you for 600
million dollars
as for the charges
I believe I deserve some recognition
from this board
I'm sorry
yes
I don't understand which part
[Music]
foreign
have you ever had a dream Neo that you
were so sure was real
what if you were unable to wake from
that dream how would you know the
difference between the dream world
and the real world
what is happening to me the answer is up
there Neo it's the question that drives
us
what is the Matrix
The Matrix is the world that has been
pulled over your eyes to Blind you from
the truth
what truth they're watching you neo
human being
you are a Cancer
or the Cure
get me the hell out of here
welcome
to the real world
[Music]
here to save the world that's what do
you need guns lots of guns no one has
ever done anything like this that's why
it's going to work buckle you seat belt
Dorothy because Kansas is going bye-bye
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
unfortunately no one can be told what
the Matrix is
you have to see it for yourself
[Music]
in a dark time when hope was bleak
there lived a young girl
whose only Escape
was in a legend
that wanted her back
the legend speaks of the lost soul of a
princess
from another world who will one day be
reborn
there will be signs
[Music]
that Mark her return
there will be secrets
that reveal her destiny
[Music]
there will be a journey
that will make you believe
[Music]
foreign
picture house
[Music]
and the imagination of Guillermo del
Toro
[Music]
the darkness
there can be light
in misery there can Beauty
in death there can be life
[Music]
Pan's Labyrinth
foreign
[Music]
thank you
so I am
[Music]
never
mind
[Music]
foreign
communities
[Music]
thank you
Where Do We Begin
a year ago these uh cops and lawyers
wouldn't dare cross any of you I mean
what happened
so what are you proposing it's simple
kill the Batman
here's my card
Bruce this is Harvey Dent Rachel's told
me everything about you no certainly
hope not
he always told me that we'd be together
did you mean it Chris don't make me your
only hope for normal life
you're Alfred right that's right sir any
psychotic ex-boyfriends I should be
aware of oh you have no idea
good evening ladies and gentlemen
we are tonight's entertainment
well hello beautiful
you look nervous
see now would have to become to stop men
like him
the night is dark as just before the
dawn
I promise you the dawn is coming
and here we
we go
this city deserves a better class of
criminal
I'm gonna give it to him no
we'll see I'll show you
or die a hero
or you live long enough to see yourself
become the villain
will you be one in the back butcher in
the middle of the day Alfred not very
subtle the Lamborghini
much more subtle
what happened there was an accident
a car accident
[Music]
and blue velvet
could be someone's missing the girl is
Missing
I just came here from Deep River Ontario
and now I'm in this
place
I don't know who I am that money you
don't know where it came from
[Music]
oh by the way those two detectives came
by again looking for you someone is in
trouble something bad is happening you
got me scared
there is no band and yet
we hear a band
I remember something
what is it what do you see
Holland Drive that's where I was going
Diane the car's waiting
you coming
okay
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
in this Wasteland I am the one who runs
from both the living and the dead
a man reduced to a single instinct
thank you survive
it is by my hand
you arrived
[Music]
From the Ashes
of this world
we
we are not things
foreign
Ty
oh what a day what a lovely day
you want to get through this let's go
[Music]
as the world fell
to us in our own way was broken
it was hard to know who was more crazy
thank you
for everyone else
[Music]
foreign